[Music]
this is the last sunday service at
dadivan cathedral before azerbaijan
moves in
the post-war carving up of territories
which will place some of armenia's most
sacred religious sites in the hands of
their enemy
[Music]
this war has been painful enough
but the loss of these ancient
monasteries and churches is especially
bitter for the world's first
christian nation
it's our heritage and we should visit
and we should protect our heritage
unfortunately it will become part of
azerbaijan it's
painful but i don't want to say goodbye
because i'm sure
i'm sure that i'll be back russian
peacekeepers are here to make sure that
that happens
azerbaijan has promised that christians
will continue to have access to sites
like daddy bank
once the kalbaja region is handed over
on wednesday but armenians have a hard
time believing it
is
foreign on friday in the mosque at agdam
azerbaijan held its first prayers since
the city fell to armenian forces in
1993.
both sides claim the other has destroyed
and vandalized its cultural heritage
but armenia's territorial claims are in
large part based on the existence of
these ancient churches
on land which under international law
belongs to azerbaijan
the amaras monastery dates back to the
start of the 4th century
in around 4 10 a.d the inventor of the
armenian alphabet founded the first
school to use his script here we're in
the southeast of nagorno-karabakh
where azerbaijan has reconquered a lot
of territory and in fact their positions
are just
on the top of that hill three kilometers
away this monastery is
under the protection for now the next
five years at least of russian
peacekeepers
even though it's armenian troops who are
guarding it at the moment
but it just does show you how precarious
these very
important sites for armenian
christianity are
nineteen-year-old salav stationed at
amaras lost
foreign
the status quo now is fragile
monasteries like amaras militarized
zones
but guarding them is better than being
in the trenches where while this
conflict re-freezes
troops on both sides will stay
sky news